[Music]
so
back in the early 2000s silicon valley
promoted big data as the means to
revolutionize not only marketing and
business but the scientific method
itself
theories were no longer necessary or
desirable
physics and biology were to be
transformed
yet the claimed scientific breakthroughs
have
not yet materialized and instead of
being neutral and value-free many argue
that in actual fact big data embeds the
prejudices of those writing the code
so should we reject the claims for big
data as marketing hype for
big tech
should we conclude theories are not only
necessary but
unavoidable or might developments in
computing power enable machines to
identify patterns that are more powerful
than any human theories that have ever
been dreamed up by us and in turn bring
us to a better picture of reality
so to answer that question i turn to our
our speakers
first we have kenneth cookier who is an
american journalist writer and author
he's most acclaimed for his
contributions to the economist magazine
and his book big data a revolution that
will transform how we work
live and think co-authored with victor
meyer schomburger
notcher mares is an author the u and
professor at the university of warwick
her work is uh focused on science and
technology and society and how they
overlap with public policy and everyday
life
joanna bryson to my left is professor of
ethics and technology at hertes school
in berlin and is a founding member of
the center for digital governance and
since july 2020 professor bryson has
been one of the nine experts nominated
by germany to the global partnership for
artificial intelligence so the question
we're trying to tackle on this panel
today is
were the claims that big data should
replace scientific theory
just marketing hype for big tech and to
kick us off we're going to turn to
kenneth who i hope can actually explain
what big data is
and in some way help us ask answer that
question
absolutely thank you luke so let's first
take us i've got three minutes now i've
got two and a half
let's first remember what data is
right data the information is all around
us everything is informational the the
the beautiful dulce tones of the baby
crying you know the the lovely uh um
sunlight and then the you know the wind
that goes through and
if we wanted to quantify that so that we
could reuse it and interact with it we
would datify it we'd render it into a
data format we took something that was
informational and turned it into data
and then we could maybe store it we
could run analyses of it and find out
that it's likely to rain under these
conditions or not so that's data so what
is big data well big data was it was a
sort of a shorthand
to refer to this idea that we have more
data sources than ever before but not
just more in a linear sense like i have
10 and today i've got 20.
but in the exponential sense that had
gone in sort of in sort of if you will
from factors from 10 to 100 to a
thousand but if you do that again and
again suddenly when in a universe where
you had 10 of something you now have 10
billion of something and if you have
that sort of scale of difference which
you did get with transistors for example
suddenly you can do new things with 10
billion of something say observations of
weather patterns that you couldn't do
when you only had smaller amounts of it
say 10 of it
so the term big data was the shorthand
for that but it was also a shorthand for
machine learning a statistic a technique
of basically statistics but in the
family of ai that went from
not really from working a little bit but
not much in the 1950s and 60s to
something that showed huge problem
promise by 2010 uh image recognition
systems online translation are examples
but the key thing is this behind the
concept of machine learning is a
statistical
um or algorithmic
term or concept of
feature extraction and that is to say
that you don't know at the outset
what is the relevant variable
but depending on the output you want to
get the system identifies what's
relevant and then
looks for it and then is able to
identify it and learn something new
about this body of data that you didn't
know before let me give you
two very quick examples
of looking at examples of retinas if you
have millions of people's retinas not
only can you identify
features from it such as whether they're
a smoker or their age
but their sex whether they're male or
female and that turns out to be
incredibly important because the
practitioners and the science didn't
know that the retina would actually
encode
a person's gender
just there's no theory behind it there's
there's nothing for a human being to
look at the retina scan and know to look
for to identify it
yet there's something in there that we
can identify
now if you take that that concept just
as a as a principle that there is going
to be this body of of this quotient of
information
unknown to the human mind that can be
identified in a large body of data
through these new techniques suddenly
let's look at where in the sciences we
can apply this new method and here's
where i'll end because i know time is
ticking
protein folding and lo and behold deep
mind had a system alpha fold that was
able to predict the ways in which
proteins would fold which turns out to
be incredibly complex and also turns out
to be incredibly beneficial if you want
to design new medications
so i look at us at a session and the
title that it is now are the claims of
big data
just marketing hype for big tech and i
have to pull out my hair and wonder on
what planet is
is the institute of art and ideas
because big data's making huge
contributions already and we should
embrace it thank you
well there we go we're done we can we
can leave now um but maybe maybe joanna
we should turn to you so big data the
big opportunity or a big problem
both of course but i'm not going to
answer that i'm going to go ahead and
and talk about the first question you
asked um uh and i and i won't uh say
that uh i am going to say aren't they
that uh if if you can tell sex from
retinas you might not be able to tell
gender from retinas
but uh anyway i don't know that i i
haven't seen the day there may you may
be able to tell gender too uh but
where are we let's talk about models
unless so it actually comes down to a
great uh introduction on the data and
the data science i want to do a little
bit of an introduction on science so we
often get told that what science is
about is you take uh you have you have
two theories and then you get some data
and you compare those theories and then
the one that that fits the the data
better wins right it's like a game right
now in fact uh
it's not quite that simple because you
have to define better sometimes a much
more complicated theory will match the
data better
but it will only match that data and it
won't be as good at predicting the
future so in machine learning we call
that overfitting in science we often we
favor as simple of theory as possible
because we're basically trying to make
an abstraction we're trying to
understand the world and predict things
from the world and be able to do useful
things with the world you know and like
useful things for ourselves now we need
to do useful things for the planet
for ourselves but anyway the point is
you pick a level of abstraction at which
you can get things done
okay so
i have definitely heard uh people from
big tech and indeed uh people who just
take lots of money from big tech
saying things like oh now i'm gonna
correct you too sorry
at the beginning you said that uh you
know that programmers introduce uh
bias with their programming into into
data it's it's more it's different than
that that i was one of the people that
authored the paper that was in science
in 2017
showing that uh if you train
um ai on
the stuff that we all produce our you
know our language the internet things
like that you wind up with the same
implicit biases that we have it's not
surprising and the same we in the same
paper we showed that those implicit
biases reflect our lived reality so a
lot of things that are called sexist and
racist are like pointing out that
actually women and people of color are
living different lives than men and
people of no color i don't know what the
option is there but anyway that you that
these things do have consequences in
your lives
and when we talk about when we when we
try i'm not saying that implicit bias
doesn't matter but that explicitly we're
negotiating for a better future and the
ai like some of our our backgrounds uh
we'll come up with responses that are
based on a lot of old 1950s television
shows that we don't want to reflect the
current world okay if that makes sense
all right so
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you